makeup was one of the biggest things  that sold during the Great Depression  that's right makeup escapism a little  taste of normality a little smile really  matters during tough times so when so  it's kind of headline immediately you  could be like hmm what that makes no  sense but in reality this is why I have  so much love for all the entertainers  the comedian  musicians creative class that during  tougher times give a little hope to  athletes Sports it does it for me they  give a little excitement a little  escapism from their normal tough  realities the macro economy is getting  challenged but if you as an entrepreneur  or as a Creator or as a human being can  provide some escapism a little Joy a  little smirk a couple of hours of  smiling  actually find some fruitfulness during  tough times understand this headline